welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka tiny Dick
Grayson and since our video yesterday
we've had a whole host of brand new
updates on the Batman normally every
week
same bat-time same bat-channel we go
over the biggest updates on the movie
but this week has been completely packed
and there's a lot more information and
what could be in the film so I thought
I'd do a follow-up from yesterday on
some of the brand new tidbits throughout
this video we'll be discussing some big
plot leaks the new casting call that
could be bringing Robin into the
universe and Ben Affleck's comments on
while at the project there will be some
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the film then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a video
and without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of the
Batman ok so we have a brand new call
sheet that has just come out from the
casting Department of the film this
states at the movie is looking for
circus performers such as fire dancers
fire breathers fire stars twisted fire
starters and popper operators the people
must be age 17 and above and filming
will star in March what's interesting
about this is that it's being shot in
Liverpool and yesterday we reported on a
call for extras at Halloween party that
will be shot at the exact same location
so the city looks like it's going to
become a major area for the film and
lining these two up it is possible that
they could be the same place or linked
with one another the first casting call
that centers around the circus could
indicate that we are finally getting a
live-action Robin for the first time in
decades The Dark Knight Rises hinted at
John Blake becoming him but since Batman
and Robin and the character hasn't been
seen on screen
we know that bat flex version had one
but that he died after being murdered by
Holly in the Joker and with this being a
year two story it does make sense to
introduce him here it is said that the
movie will be based on the Batman
graphic novel the long Halloween and
whilst Robin isn't in that he does
appear in its direct sequel dog victory
and that serves as his origin story the
villain in dog victory is known as the
hangman and they leave clues behind in
the form of the game of the same
named Robin brings a completely new
perspective to the case and there's an
awesome moment when he solves the clue
that they and the readers have been
obsessing over he figures out one of
them is none of you are safe instead of
nine of you are safe and this opens
Bruce up to bringing someone else into
the family that he can train and get a
new perspective from long Halloween and
dark victory are very similar storylines
and both center around a killer striking
big names in Gotham so I currently see
them making two films out of the arc it
is more likely that they would just pick
and choose from both in order to tell
one complete story now I have seen some
people asking why not just ask for
acrobats if it's going to be centered
around the flying Grayson's and to
answer that I would say that this is
because they would likely be a higher
profile part of the scene they would
have been specifically cast and they
wouldn't just be a general call-out as
they have with extras the fact that they
are reaching out for circus folk does
add a lot of weight to the idea that
Robin will be brought into the universe
the scene could literally take place
anywhere in the movie from Bruce's
origin itself all the way up to a
post-credits scene Martha's favorite
thing to do was go and watch Hayley
circus so it could be a big moment from
Bruce's childhood or it could be added
to the end of the movie to tease what's
to come there's tons of things that we
can speculate over and it's very
exciting and if anyone can do Robin
Wright then it's definitely Matt Reeves
now there are other potential things
that the scene could be and we do know
that the penguin will be in the film
the circus is tied in with his origin
story as he used to be part of the
freakshow this appears in some of the
backstory on the character and it could
tie directly into the movie either way
there's a lot to pull from it and the
second casting call in Liverpool to sets
up a lot of things that sheet sent us on
a Halloween party that says people won't
need to bring any clothes across and it
is possible that they could be audience
members of the circus or part of
something completely unrelated as we
said earlier we do know that the movie
will be based on the book the long
Halloween so it is possible that this
could be the event that kick-starts the
entire thing the source material starts
at a wedding hosted by Falcone who we
know will be in the film whilst this
takes place in June it could be that
they are streamlining things and putting
it there to make the events happen
the opening centered around Falcone
trying to bribe Bruce but as I'm sure
you can guess he turned this down from
there the murders begin to happen and
it's a pivotal scene in the story I
would absolutely love to see a costume
party and then to have Bruce show up in
regular clothes
this happened in Batman Returns and The
Dark Knight Rises and both were
brilliant moments laced with the subtext
that Bruce Wayne was the mask that
Batman Perron in order to appear normal
either way both these casting calls give
us a lot of things to speculate about as
for things we have a bit more
information on we have some leaks that
are currently making the rounds that
talk about who the funeral scene is for
before we get into that I just from let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of the nfinity saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the updates in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random and the 15th
of March in the cell be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
okay so if you checked out yesterday's
video then you'll know that we reported
on a casting call and leaked that there
was going to be a funeral scene in the
film this moment would lead to Batman
being attacked by a villain and having
his bat suit destroyed unless he
required a new one since then we've had
a lot more leaked surface on what this
is in regards to and who is behind it
according to the leaks the character
that is killed is the mayor of Gotham
and this is who the funeral is being
held for in addition to this the mayor's
death is reportedly the big event that
we saw the news vans police and Bruce
Wayne investigating this was at the spot
where all of the Gotham Action News vans
were and where Bruce pulled up on his
motorbike and looked over the scene the
funeral pulls the entirety of Gotham
together and it's during this that the
Riddler is meant to attack this comes
directly from the person on set who
dropped a picture of Robert Pattinson
chair and then went on to have their
account deleted along with all of their
posts and probably their career we did
report yesterday that Leake has said
that during this Batman's costume is
severely damaged and that he must
replace the cape and cowl we go into all
of the details on the new costume in
that video so definitely check it out if
you haven't but basically the cowl gets
white eyes and loses the collar to it
I'll leave that video linked at the end
if you want to know more and yeah
definitely go check that out
now the death of the mayor is something
massive as in some Batman storylines
most of the earth one the penguin was
the mayor it could be possible that the
villains in the film are working
together as is often the case in movies
which they end up having more than one
and the penguin could have hired The
Riddler to kill the mayor so that he can
take his place this would allow the
penguin to rule Gotham and him running
for mayor was something that was seen in
the sixty-six show and the
aforementioned film Batman Returns
it's an incredible bit of information
that shows not even the mayor is safe in
Gotham this cements the need for a
Batman and makes for an amazing plot
point if true and finally we have an
interview that's just come out from Ben
Affleck that says why left the project
and decided to make way for the new
vision when athlet was pretty much doing
the hokey-cokey for about three years
with him being in one second and out the
other and because of this he came to be
known as Schrodinger's bat ultimately
after several delays he decided to step
away and is now finally revealed why
this was an interview with the New York
Times
applix said that he struggles with
alcohol and his divorce from Jennifer
Garner led to a troubled shootin Justice
League this swayed him to step down and
when discussing the matter he said I
showed somebody the Batman script and
they said I think the script is good I
also think you'll drink yourself to
death if he go through what you just
went through again Affleck said he drank
relatively normally but due to stress in
his life he started to lose control he
followed this up by saying what happened
was that I started drinking more and
more when my marriage was falling apart
he trying to make yourself feel better
with eating or drinking or sex or
gambling or shopping or whatever but
that ends up making your life worse then
you do more of it to make that
discomfort go away then the real pain
starts it becomes a vicious cycle you
can't break that's at least what
happened to me sadly a flex marriage to
garner ended in 2018 and I just find
reading this a bit of a bummer Affleck
is a big comic book fan and I remember
him saying that he wanted to do Batman
for so long and that it was a dream come
true
I still love his version of the
character but obviously he has to put
himself before the role and it's not
nice to read stuff like that it's a
shame
pretty much ruined your day have enough
oh well I am this spoiler man and it
looks like a spoiled days to know anyway
that's all of the new since yesterday
and I can't believe how much we're
getting on the movie at the moment I
love this part of the production as it
really lets the imagination run wild and
you can pour over every single detail I
would love to hear your thoughts on the
Batman updates so comment below and let
me know make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
if you want something else to watch then
definitely check out our video from
yesterday in which you go over the
second Batsuit leaks in full detail we
also did a full breakdown of the insane
details that you missed in Joker which
is gonna be linked at the end it's one
of the best videos I've ever done and if
you loved the movie you definitely need
to check that out you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you access the content early and
can suggest video topics and breakdowns
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you